bonjour à tous on voit que quand on
décale d'une demi heure ça va mieux un
bon donc je passe la parole à lydia pour
le point l'agenda alors l'agenda de la
semaine demain mardi 8h30 donc il y aura
la matinée de travail consacrée à la
sécurité avec discours de clôture du
président nicolas sarkozy
à 16h30 le président rencontrera patrick
bouvet le président du conseil national
de l'ordre des médecins médecins qui ont
qui ont manifesté il ya quelques
quelques semaines comme comme d'autres
professions comme les avocats comme les
gardiens de prison et tellement d'autres
qui manifestent leur mécontentement de
la politique du gouvernement
à 18h le bureau politique se réunira
mercredi commission exécutive comme tous
les mercredis à 17 heures 19 heures les
rendez vous du projet à l'initiative
d'eric woerth sur le thème la mobilité
des jeunes en europe ce sera animée par
françoise grossetête constance le grip
et isabelle le callennec sera cela aura
lieu évidemment aussi j'ai des
républicains le samedi 7 novembre donc
notre conseil national qui aura lieu à
la mutualité avec discours de laurent
wauquiez nicole nicolas sarkozy
évidemment ncaa m
valérie pécresse gérard larcher alain
juppé jean pierre raffarin
trois tables rondes sur le bilan de la
gauche dans les régions notre
proposition économique pour les régions
et puis notre projet de manière plus
plus globale pour la région et un
discours de clôture de nicolas sarkozy
donc ça c'est samedi 7 novembre à la
mutualité
alors ce
week-end le gouvernement a fait une
découverte c'est qu' un certain nombre
de retraités allait être soumis aux
impôts locaux
nous pensons que cette situation est due
au matraquage sans précédent mise en
place matraquage fiscal sans précédent
mise en place par françois hollande et
son équipe
mais pour se défausser bien évidemment
ça doit être la faute à la majorité
précédente
et donc on nous dit que ce serait dû à
une loi de 2008 tenez vous bien 2008
nous sommes en 2015 ça veut dire il ya
sept ans ça fait trois ans et demi que
françois hollande est arrivé à l'elysée
et si par extraordinaire c'était
effectivement dus à une loi de 2008 que
healy à cette situation aujourd'hui
au bout de trois ans et demi demanda
quel amateurisme
quelle incompétence de s'apercevoir
qu'il va y avoir et bien une telle
conséquence sur les impôts locaux d'un
certain nombre de retraités
véritablement on a l'impression que
françois hollande découvre tous les
jours qu'il est président de la
république et qu'il doit faire des
réformes
à ce titre là et donc on est dans cette
situation assez invraisemblable qu'un
premier ministre qu'un ministre du
budget 10 aux retraités de ne pas payer
leurs impôts
je sais pas si vous avez vu mais
monsieur eckert a annoncé qu'il ne
fallait pas payer les impôts locaux pour
les retraités qui sont qui sont touchés
par cette disposition qui leur fait pour
la première fois payer les impôts locaux
donc on a l'impression d'être finalement
dans une république bananière on a
quitté l'état de droit puisque même les
ministres disent qu'il ne faut pas payer
ses impôts dans quel monde vivons nous
c'est une affaire qui est assez qui
assez comique puisque beaucoup de
députés notamment les fondeurs allait
déjà attiré l'attention du gouvernement
sur sur la question
des des retraites avec des revenus
modestes fin 2013 un amendement avait
été déposé pour rétablir cette demi part
dit demi part des vins ça a été recalé
par le gouvernement ça a été recalé par
par manuel valls
en 2014 il avait encore attiré
l'attention du gouvernement
ils n'ont eu aucun écho en jouant mieux
sapin nous fait des annonces pour les
ménages les plus modestes pour dire
qu'il y aura une baisse des impôts et à
aucun moment il a traité de cette
question a de la demi part des veuves et
là comme par enchantement on peut quand
même se poser la question du calendrier
comme comme par enchantement à six
semaines des régionales ils ressortent
ce dossier alors comment et quand ils
vont rembourser ces retraités on ne sait
pas pourquoi ont-ils attendu que les
avis arrive dans les boîtes aux lettres
pour faire cette annonce
on ne sait pas moi je pense que c'est
encore une fois du mensonge qu'ils ne
vont pas remboursés c'est ces retraités
et que c'est exclusivement fait à des
fins électoralistes
voilà c'est cdu c'est du sensationnel et
je me demande pourquoi ils n'ont pas
écouté leurs députés pourquoi il affiche
autant de mépris aussi à l'endroit des
retraités puisque il a annoncé ça avec
un simple tweet on sait très bien que je
pense que il fait beaucoup de retraités
qui utilisent leur twitter pour pour
avoir les annonces du gouvernement donc
à travers un tweet il annonce 7,7
revenir sur cette décision
je trouve que c'est éminemment méprisant
des retraités l affaire air cocaïne
c'est je dirais que c'est celle à faire
de trop l'acharnement sur nicolas
sarkozy bon on le connaît ça fait des
années que ça dure
mais là c'est le sait la faire qui
démontre le ridicule de cette de cet
acharnement de la justice
voilà on veut absolument des
explications claires notamment sur la
géolocalisation
il faut quand même rappeler peut-être
que c'est utile de le rappeler
le juge d'instruction doit instruire à
charge mais aussi à décharge et on se
demande pour qui il n'inscrit pas
exclusivement à charge lorsqu'il s'agit
de nicolas sarkozy s'il n'a ce truc pas
exclusivement de manière aveugle et
partial lorsqu'il s'agit de nicolas
sarkozy je pense que cette cet
acharnement doit maintenant cesser ça
vire au ridicule et tous reliés
l'ancien président de la république
président du premier parti de france
un trafic de drogue international juste
parce qu'il a pris un avion c'est c'est
absolument ridicule et d'autres
personnes personnalité de notre famille
politique on fait une comparaison avec
avec un taxi c'est comme si on prenait
le taxi est que le chauffeur de taxi été
arrêté pour trafic de drogue
est-ce qu'on va demander les factures
géolocaliser mettre en place voilà
différentes différentes mesures pour
créer un lien artificiel avec avec le
trafiquant c'est une affaire qui est
absolument invraisemblable et on voit
pas sur quels indices ce fonds de la
justice pour pourquoi elle ne cible que
nicolas sarkozy et pas l'ensemble des
utilisateurs de cette de cet avion hier
sur bfm christiane taubira était assez
floues a dans ses déclarations
mais ce n'est pas la première fois
qu'elle est qu'elle est assez floue et
qu'elle tombe dans dans le mensonge
elle avait déjà démontré avec l' affaire
des écoutes les années taubira vont
décidément être marquée par le laxisme
mais aussi par l'acharnement de la
justice à l'endroit de l'ancien
président de la république nicolas
sarkozy
donc voila et puis encore une fois c'est
assez étrange de voir que cela arrive
juste avant les régionales
et d'ailleurs nous posons donc plusieurs
questions la première c'est est ce que
le même traitement a été réservé à
l'ensemble des utilisateurs de cette
compagnie aérienne première question
deuxième question s'il y a eu chaud kyo
localisation et étude des fadettes
y at il eu également etc
téléphonique troisième question madame
taubira était elle au courant de cette
affaire et du fait qu'il a été mené une
enquête sur nicolas sarkozy
décidément avec le recul cette phrase
souvenez-vous de françois hollande
sarkozy je le surveille
je sais exactement ce qu'il fait prend
tout son sens et on a vu il ya quelques
jours un reportage sur canal+ un
reportage d'eric m'en donner et de jules
girona qui montrait comment françois
hollande instrumentaliser la justice
avec l'utilisation des archives de
l'elysée on peut se poser la question de
savoir jusqu'où va cette
instrumentalisation est ce que ça n'est
pas encore un exemple de l'indus de
l'instrumentalisation de la justice par
françois hollande alors ce week-end nous
avons fait une autre découverte
décidément le week-end il se passe
beaucoup de choses
c'est ce qu'on peut appeler le lucette
gate
c'est à dire que la semaine dernière
françois hollande qui se déplaçait en
tournée électorale à vandoeuvre les
nancy avait semblé en tout cas ça a été
présenté comme cela à la presse et aux
français s'inviter chez une petite dame
qui s'appelle lucette est donc
apparemment c'était à l'occasion d'un
café pris spontanément chez l'habitant
et où nous avons découvert que
finalement en réalité ce qu'a fait cette
rencontre était pour le moins très
organisé
tout était préparé à l'avancé les
questions qu'elle est posée françois
hollande
le café était préparée par les services
municipaux
l'état s'était municipal les chaises
étaient municipal les fleurs étaient
municipal et lucette avait eu droit à la
visite d'un représentant de l'elysée
pour la briefer sur ce qu'elle devait
dire elle avait il y avait des choses
qu'elles avaient le droit de dire et il
y avait des choses qui lui était
interdit d'évoquer notamment et elle l'a
fait sous les caméras de bfm tv
elle aurait bien voulu demander à
françois hollande pourquoi est ce qui
faisait tant pour un certain nombre
d'immigrés et pourquoi est ce qui
laissait mourir dans la rue un certain
nombre de sdf et donc ça ne faisait pas
bien dans le reportage
et donc elle a été interdite de
questions relevant de l'immigration
puisque c'est un sujet qui fâche et
qu'il ne fallait pas abordés et donc on
s'aperçoit que dans la lignée de la
campagne électorale présidentielle de
2012 avec françois hollande
on est dans le mensonge permanent
l'elysée est devenu une gigantesque
agence de communication au service d'un
président en perdition et d'ailleurs
cette agence de communication a
fonctionné encore récemment à l'occasion
d'un reportage attendent président fait
par yves jeuland où on s'apercevait que
finalement que le personnage clé de
l'elysée c'était le communicant gaspard
gander et donc
j'observe que également en termes de
communication et bien
françois hollande marquent à la culotte
nicolas sarkozy nicolas sarkozy avait
fait une interview sur tf1 le lundi
suivant
françois hollande fait une grande
interview sur rtl
la semaine dernière nicolas sarkozy
faisait un direct de russie sur bfm tv
françois hollande va faire demain une
émission en direct sur europe 1 depuis
la chine est donc la question qui se
pose c'est quelle est cette attitude
d'un président de la république qui
marquent à la culotte je pense que c'est
bien ça le terme est bien le président
du principal parti d'opposition
je crois que françois hollande a été élu
président de la république jusqu'en 2017
il n'a pas été élu pour un demi-mandat
et ensuite avoir l'autre moitié du
mandat en campagne électorale
en réaction à chaque fois ce que fait le
président de la principale formation
politique d'opposition